two security officers being hailed as
Heroes tonight their quick thinking
helped them see the signs of an overdose
and do everything they could to Save a
Life Victoria Saha spoke with the
officers and how they're training help
prepare them for this moment it's a
story you'll only see on eight news now
what started as a normal date of Patrol
for two security officers quickly turned
into a life or death situation here by
University and Twain the officers not
hesitating as they stepped into action
every situation is always a touchy one
security officers often see the bad the
ugly and then the scary I know the
longer and longer we wait
you know there's a chance that these
guys may not make it security
sir Stephen McGinnis and Sergeant
Jeffrey Carpenter with protective Force
International regularly Patrol together
but recently they came across two people
unconscious in a car they knew something
was wrong recognizing signs of OD is the
pale the clammy skin the blue the purple
lips it was a functional overdose a drug
that can turn deadly quick kick these
guys out it's all the security officers
could think about as they turn to the
only tool they could use in that moment
Narcan how we train is how we perform
when it's time to work it's an
adrenaline rush just before this
incident to the force recently
implemented use of Narcan training
according to Jonathan Alvarez CEO of
protective force it just solidifies that
every single one of our security
officers needs to go through the
training and carry this type of
equipment the security officers each
doing their part to save two lives
before paramedics arrived we are the
First Responders to the First Responders
Victoria sahab 8 News Now
Victoria has learned that the two
individuals have survived this overdose
after several uses of Narcan